[Music]
i'm stephen wilsher i do drawings
steven is an artist who creates
incredibly intricate drawings of
cityscapes i love drawing tall buildings
tall skyscrapers skylines street scenes
and he does this entirely from memory
when stephen was three he was diagnosed
as autistic
he was completely mute and lived
entirely in his own world
early on stephen's teachers noticed he
loved to draw
he had found his way to connect with
others
stephen has the ability to look at a
subject once and then draw an accurate
and detailed picture of it including
panoramas of entire cities based off
just a quick look i go up on the
helicopter and then memorize it and then
after being on a helicopter and then
straight back at the hotel and then
started to draw
his incredible talent launched an
artistic career that has taken him
around the world
los angeles dubai houston texas
and
tokyo and japan and that's just to name
a few new york's my favorite empire
state building
chrysler building and there are lots of
yellow
new york taxi cabs and steven has no
plans of stopping anytime soon someone
told me that
people like me drawings
feel good always be happy about it
[Music]
uh
the idea came from my father
[Music]
he told me about their pictures on the
walls
and the subway stations
of old buildings you know old new york
20 years later after going through
everything school college and all that
stuff i thought i would finally give it
a look and to see what my father was
talking about
it was going to be a short article
i was going to illustrate some stations
with some pictures and tell the stories
but it
kind of ran away with me
what i've set out to do is make a record
of the appearance of the subway stations
in new york city
take drawings of the mosaic or fountains
designs on the walls which embellish the
stations
i devote as much of my time as i can to
doing it
evenings or weekends vacation time even
you know it's all it's a sort of a
consuming um project
so far
i've completed four volumes on one two
three and four
my ambition is to take care of all the
lines until
all 490
496 or 169
470 stations have been
recorded and seen
[Music]
why am i doing it
[Music]
okay
my purpose in doing this study is to
make a record of what we've got
i want to like document when it was done
and who did it
so that's what i wanted to do that's my
focus is to give credit to those who
made it possible
i really started in earnest in 1978
and i thought i'd get this project
finished and wrapped up by the year 2030
which is only 14 years from now
perhaps i have to re-estimate and
suggest maybe
closer to 2040.
i'll be
in my 90s
then hope i can still see
[Music]
the pleasure of doing the job is
his payment
i'm committed to it that's all it's my
pr it's my purpose it's my life
it's become
my identity
so i have to live up to it
[Music]
these paintings they aren't done with
acrylic oil or watercolor
[Music]
microsoft excel the computer program
this is a story about tatsuo the
microsoft excel artist
[Music]
when tatsu retired he decided he wanted
to paint but there was one problem
he was cheap
he didn't even want to pay for an art
program so he used what was already on
his computer
so how do you paint in excel the line
tool it's usually used for spreadsheet
graphs that you can make trees with and
the bucket tool it helps with subtle
shading on for example the crest of a
volcano this week
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
skin
[Music]
i just want to start and go and go and
go
the longest amount of time that i can
draw
before the tide comes in and washes
everything away
[Applause]
my name is jim donovan i draw in the
sand
to draw on the sand it's a balance
between a mental game and a
physical they're both equally important
i started drawing in the sand
a little more than 20 years ago
i was walking along the beach one day it
just came to me to use it as a canvas
i just put my finger in the sand and
made a
giant fish
i became really really obsessed with it
i left behind the world both of surfing
and the job as a chef and i just put
everything
into drawing in the sand there was
almost no one in the whole world that
did this kind of thing
i've drawn in sand around the world
australia uruguay argentina chile russia
i mean occasionally it's a mission but
i'm also in places where oh there's a
nice patch of sand i think i'll go do
something there
the one that was 10 miles in
circumference in the desert on dry lake
it's a goodness world record largest art
i walked as much as 30 miles in one day
which means about seven or eight hours
of walking
i like the stick probably the best
because i like to come down to the beach
with nothing
the tools are sitting there on the beach
sticks to choose from and i'll
do my composition
do a nice big drawing and then i'll
throw the stick away come down with
nothing and leave with nothing for me
that's the most fulfilling choice of how
to do it
drawing the sand is the ultimate of in
the moment and i want to finish when the
tide is about to destroy the drawing
this is going to change every day
anything i do down there is going to be
gone and every time i'm going to have a
big huge place to try something new
[Music]
making drawings on land on quite a large
scale is something people can do for
thousands of years
[Music]
i'm simon beck
and i make drugs in the snow
[Music]
it started as a bit of fun
but gradually he's taken over my life
a ballpark estimate of footsteps
about 5000 steps in an hour
a big drawing
two hours measuring eight hours work
you're looking at forty thousand steps
[Music]
i started doing it as an easy
alternative to hiki at the mountain when
i wanted some exercise
you're starting with a drawer on a piece
of paper
or else you're drawing in your mind
just treating it a bit like an
orienteering map
you're just going a certain distance in
a certain direction
to determine distances by counting bases
it's a very physical exercise it's
equivalent to a long days walking in the
hills when you make one of these big
drawings
[Music]
i'm just about the only person in the
world doing anything like it
[Music]
[Music]
you